une toile de 17 m une toile qui invite à
danser à bouger ou juste à écouter flow
612 sort tout droit de l'imagination du
chorégraphe daniel larrieu pensée pour
les enfants l'installation a aussi été
créé avec les élèves de l'école pierre
vue d'un à paris daniel larrieu l'a
conçu vraiment dans un espace de liberté
c'est-à-dire que quand les enfants dans
cette boîte n'ont aucune consigne
ils peuvent danser ils peuvent marcher
courir bouger ou alors ils peuvent juste
contempler le décor donc c'est vraiment
un espace de liberté pour une bande son
et des lumières qui évolue avec les
mouvements grâce à 48 capteurs au sol
moi personnellement ce parce que je
trouve très incroyable c'est le décor
selon si la lumière est vert bleu rouge
ça fait apparaître des éléments du décor
et ça je trouve ça assez magique tout
proche dans la chapelle une deuxième
exposition celle de florence rochelle et
son spectacle permanent
c'est un lieu qui me touchent et j'avais
envie
d'abord que ce que j montrait
entrant en résonance est en relation
avec ce lieu est en même temps le laisse
le laisse visible j'avais pas envie de
masquer ou de de mettre trop de choses
qui voilà qui aurait qui aurait fait
qu'on ne verrait plus la chapelle des
oeuvres détourné réalisé avec l'aide du
fab lab de saint-quentin-en-yvelines une
expérience hybride où s'entremêlent les
disciplines